hello and welcome to this video playing
forgotten prophecy I definitely need
some beverage here the double team Karen
has served me well over the years as an
opening gym to play once in a while a
common mistake is to take with an eidm
there they all do it and that is a
strategic mistake taking with a pawn is
a lot better this position is very
comfortable for white but I mean it's
nothing that you can expect to win
quickly but it is very comfortable to
play the knight will try to go to d5 and
it's very difficult for black to get any
sort of counter play you're basically
just sitting there in a passive position
in this particular case I can even take
with the pawn and that will take because
taking with the pawn playing f110 95 is
extremely uncomfortable we'll see how
this works out if you don't know this
position it might sound a bit odd that I
think that black is already in a bit of
trouble but you would seem and again
it's not like he's losing but it is it's
not very it's not much fun
and they said totally forgot about that
he has this it changes the whole
situation a little bit admittedly no I
don't think about that you know that he
can place he five them hmm that's not
that's not what the doctor ordered I
tried to get in b5 so that at least my
night will not be me and that he is not
going to play Bishop c6 it's not a big
deal
actually about hmm King f8 should you
let me guess ten times I wouldn't have
come up with Kia made but it doesn't
really it doesn't hurt him any and
anyway
it just looks quite odd so do we play
with g4 here I don't know but oppa
should take sledge 3 ok I push it takes
t4 I was lucky didn't look at this
perform beforehand so if I go g4 what is
he doing sacrificing maybe I can play
wookie 7 years well right rookies 7 but
it doesn't but he committed some of you
can play it will have to go to d8 anyway
and then you can go to e3 for example
just claiming that it's a little bit
better on e3 that it was only one now
maybe it's still um not quite clear how
I'm going to make any headway in this
position sacrifice the exchange on d4
that is not totally ridiculous but also
not really convincing maybe I can do
that if he plays h5 oh okay it was fed
up with my knight but now I got an
absolutely excellent Bishop there that
gives me the soprano he had to take with
the king I think then I would only have
been slightly better
now you just push the ape on home I
think no way to stop those pawns
all the way to aah
I did not really see that he gets this
that he got this strong I would post
there and before but it didn't really
matter that much
yeah Queen edge eight meters coming I
mean it matters of course but it wasn't
a problem to say yeah I think he takes
us better um this is really a nice
position maybe it would hand side I
should just take with the take with the
bishop and there was a little bit
annoying here really with c5f for my age
or maybe I have to do something else
here well and this is probably okay for
black him okay yeah before and he
allowed to loud me to play b5 I think
this should be basically fine for black
[Music]
but he shouldn't take on d5 I think the
same the engine agree he said that that
this is a mistake
yeah yeah he has to take with the
cab-horse
a king cakes and then I'm not sure the
engine wants to play h5 you know I
wasn't I wasn't entirely certain what to
do age five maybe you know and I have I
just maintain I just have pressure and
this pollution he always has to watch
out
b7 f7 the bishop is just extremely
strong but yeah after that is just just
push the pawns home there is no way to
stop that I'm still quite maybe maybe
the simple Bishop takes this better the
problem here for black is that there are
things things possible yeah you can
place he five at some moment or if he
goes be six the problem is that a knight
on d5 cannot be expelled anymore but see
success that would weaken far too much
and very important is there is no pony
for oftentimes in the Kings Indian in
cattle there's a pawn on e4 and here
there is none so the diagonal is
actually opened them yeah the great more
says only to inaccuracies outstanding
yeah it's nice and you can always if you
look at the analysis you can briefly
check and if you don't make a blunder
usually I'm happy
okay no no big blunder everything was
kind of within reason okay guys thanks
for watching